it's vice president kamala harris to the
rescue the vice president arriving in
poland to smooth things over as
controversy erupts over a plan to send
fighter jets to ukraine harris was
originally headed to europe to rally
nato allies but mixed messaging from the
white house is now taking center stage
after secretary of state blinken gave
poland the green light to send fighter
jets to ukraine the administration was
quick to strike down the plan
now it's up to vice president kamala
harris to fix the mess
okay so it's kamala harris to the rescue
uh is she capable of comprehending the
delicate foreign policy moment uh with
the world
consequences that she's entering into
jessie this is
such a funny question
uh all right it's insulting to send
kamala harris at a time like this she
knows nothing about anything and we all
know that the europeans know that but
who else she gonna send
so she's gonna get there and they're
gonna ask her about the migs they're
gonna ask her about no-fly zones they're
gonna ask her about sanctions and things
that she just doesn't grasp and she's
going to have to think and talk on the
fly and it's not going to go well and
it's going to bring great shame and
embarrassment to the united states of
america i want to talk about something
you guys were just talking about in
terms of i totally disagree with that
but okay
wouldn't be the first time right
if you if the other option is just make
this a proxy war
how long could that last that could last
years you destroy ukraine right you
destroy ukraine you load these people up
with weapons you turn it into vietnam
like lebanon
right yep and and so that's the third
option and that's the option that the us
and the western allies are pursuing a
proxy war so that's not ending anytime
soon all right but harold i want you to
listen to uh admiral kirby talking about
this this mix-up with the migs and the
misunderstanding
we do not support the transfer of
additional fighter aircraft to the
ukrainian air force
at this time and therefore have no
desire to see them in our custody either
we believe the best way to support
ukrainian defense is by providing them
the weapons and the systems that they
need most
to defeat russian aggression in
particular
anti-armor
and air defense
your response well i i want america to
stop telling the truth in these press
conferences i don't i don't think it
gains anything to give full disclosure
to the world about every step we're
taking vis-a-vis the migs or any other
sensitive topic i think that admiral
kirby is a great guy i've known him for
a long time i was in in haiti with him
in the earthquake earthquake of 2010 uh
but
for him to go down the list
about the aircraft and so forth i want
those migs delivered by any means
necessary and i don't care if they have
to fedex them uh
in terms of vice president harris though
this is the biggest
day of her vice presidency this is the
the most herculean task she's ever been
assigned it's time now for her to shake
off the the mantle of ineffectiveness
and really
put her
tushy on the line i want her
to disappear tonight
i don't want her to go with the poles
and the hungarians and i wanted to
disappear and i want her to go into
ukraine
into western ukraine so far it's safe so
far you don't have any uh you know uh
assassination squads and so forth you
see the pictures of levi maybe she
doesn't have to go that far i think it'd
be so symbolically powerful for the vice
president of the united states to go
into the beleaguered country
visit with those refugees and see the
mamas and see the babies and uh you know
what do you need what can we america do
a poor thing i'm so sorry i will get
these bastards i want her to step up
to this historic moment and not be the
borders are in the other ridiculous job
okay all right can she be dana can she
be successful at doing anything like
that or how about reassuring our allies
look i mean it would be great it would
be great if so so let's see um she just
arrived she hasn't spoken yet but i
think another thing is she gets set up
for a disaster once again because
on the border thing that ended up
because she was asked when you're going
to the border she laughed about it they
said okay we're going to put you in
charge of the border she said okay but
i'm just going to talk about the root
causes with just these three countries
and actually it was never seen or heard
from again on the border so now you have
a situation where earlier this week as i
know it's only wednesday but on monday
we asked admiral kirby on america's
newsroom there are reports
that there's a hold up at the white
house and getting these migs out he says
no no no no hold up no everything's fine
that afternoon is when poland said hey
guess what surprise we're going to send
you
the planes and then you're going to send
them and the americans were like well
wait you no that's not what's going to
happen i'm pretty sure that kamala
harris was supposed to go today
so that she could say oh isn't it great
we got this all worked out cold and
sunny in the planes and instead because
they were dragging their feet at the
white house this is just speculation on
my part but it's pretty good speculation
i would say that they're dragging their
feet at the white house now she's going
there and she's got a public dispute
this is what i would ask what kind of
diplomacy do we have what kind of
teamwork is it where you have a dispute
like this that spills out into the
public to geraldo's point that this is
not a discussion we should be having
with the world about like how this all
went down but i think it was because the
polls tried to force the white house's
hand on it and now she has to go over
there and try to clean it up i don't
know if it can be yep go ahead greg yeah
i wonder how her laugh translates in
polish
that's mean oh it is mean and i'm going
to get meaner she is supposed to be
delivering a three-part message
it's like a book report i imagine part
one is the intro part two is root causes
and part three is the index right this
is pure this is the first time i've seen
virtue signaling as foreign policy right
they are just sending her there to send
her there
and it replaces actual real progress or
action that's the problem with virtue
signaling in general people go on
twitter they type something and they
they instead of actually doing something
so this is exactly like that i go back
to the crazy idea the mediation
why not do something an audacious
diplomatic act where you send people of
actual grand substance two american
presidents obama and bush or obama and
trump what a road picture that would be
yeah and they go and they meet with
these two guys and that what that does
is it solves some some issues you might
get a ceasefire out of it you give the
proper deference even to the madman or
the or the evil man and and you might
actually get somewhere this this is just
as i think it was used it's a kind of a
slap in the face you're sending the
least qualified vice president ever ever
to do something in the first ground war
that we've seen in europe in decades and
it's and this is what this is how we
respond this is pure
virtue signaling meaning it's entirely
worthless i just think we should get
obama and trump on the same plane
together just to do this yeah this is
the wackiest idea i've ever come up with
yeah but you know what trump would fly
his own bro you can tell
barack wants a lift
maybe trump would fly mig-29
he says he hasn't hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else